ce qui rend depuis qu'un salon de
massage est devenu son voisin jocelyn
bel air est inquiet quand on a vu des
gars fumer du crack
avant de rentrer on a des gens qui
boivent régulièrement une bouteille de
nous tels d'alcool avant de rentrer lui
et des voisins ont cogné aux portes des
autorités municipales
il a changé
pas comment un tel établissement peut
avoir un permis de la ville dans un
quartier résidentiel
trois écoles je pense pas se met en
place pour mettre en bordel selon nos
informations les policiers sont bien au
fait de ce qui se passe ici
mais pour le maire de l'arrondissement
intervenir n'est pas aussi simple que ça
par exemple un restaurant avec serveuses
sexy c'est facile faire la démonstration
qu'il ya bien une activité non conformes
on rentre dans les restaurants et on
voit une serveuse qui dénude et on a une
preuve physique de l'activité dans le
cône au salon de massage et donc
d'activité de prostitution pour en faire
la démonstration faut constater
l'activité on peut pas envoyer les
inspecteurs faire le travail de la
police dont heureusement la petite
patrie il y à 44 salon de massage les
policiers soupçonnent qu'il ya de la
prostitution dans 13 d'entre eux le
propriétaire du salon jasmin nous a
invités à l'intérieur il concède que
certaines femmes
ici pas toutes se prostituent et puis
c'est surtout quoi reprendre chose je
leur ai dit quelques semaines voire
quelques années à l'occ la hanche et
kahn avait il est d'accord avec ses
voisins salon de massage comme le sien
devrait se trouver ailleurs que dans un
quartier résidentiel mais dit avoir un
problème à trouver un endroit où le
zonage le permettre chaque
arrondissement a lieu par
l'arrondissement ont pu le faire
l'administration coderre avait promis de
sévir contre les salons de massage et là
vous que le dossier est complexe en
penser qu'au début c'était de la traite
des femmes partout dans les salons de
massages érotiques
on s'est rendu compte que 90% des femmes
qui étaient là et elle sur une base
volontaire
nous ce qu'on s'est entendu avec le
service de police c'est que c'est
tolérance zéro pour les jeunes mineurs
donc de 16 ans et moins qui pratique ce
qu'ils font les massages érotiques pour
la traite des femmes et pour tout ce qui
est aussi échange de drogue pour
réaliser sa promesse administration
coderre qui s'en remet cette fois aux
arrondissements
elle leur demande d'envoyer des
inspecteurs
et au besoin de retirer des permis ici
françois cormier radio canada montréal